En este video vamos a construir diagramas de
Lewis, los cuales probablemente has visto antes.
Son una forma agradable de visualizar cómo
se unen los átomos en una molécula y también
los pares libres de electrones de valencia que
puedan tener diversos átomos. Así que empecemos
con un ejemplo y después presentaremos algunas
reglas para intentar dibujar estos diagramas de
Lewis. El primer ejemplo que vamos a ver es el
tetrafluoruro de silicio, tetrafluoruro es sólo
una forma elegante de decir que tenemos 4 átomos
de flúor, entonces, tetrafluoruro. En el primer
paso decimos, bueno, ¿cuáles son los electrones
que nos interesan? Y si estamos hablando de
electrones que probablemente reaccionen,
entonces hablamos de electrones de valencia,
y lo vamos a abreviar como e. v., electrones de
valencia. Entonces, pensemos en cuántos electrones
de valencia totales están involucrados en el
tetrafluoruro de silicio. Para saberlo tenemos
que pensar en cuántos electrones de valencia
tiene el silicio y después en cuántos electrones
de valencia tiene cada uno de los átomos de flúor
si sólo fueran átomos libres y neutrales, después
los multiplicaremos por 4 porque tenemos 4 átomos
de flúor. Para esto, vamos a traer nuestra tabla
periódica de los elementos. Aquí podemos ver que
la capa más externa de silicio es la tercera y en
esta tercera capa tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4 electrones de
valencia, entonces el silicio tiene 4 electrones
de valencia. A esto le sumaremos los electrones
de valencia que hay en 4 átomos de flúor, la capa
externa de un átomo libre y neutral de flúor es la
segunda capa, y en su segunda capa tiene 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7 electrones de valencia, entonces
cada flúor tiene 7 electrones de valencia,
y tenemos 4 de ellos. Podemos decir, entonces, que
en una sola molécula de tetrafluoruro de silicio
tendremos 4 + 28 electrones de valencia, esto nos
dará un total de 32 electrones de valencia. Ahora,
el paso siguiente es pensar en cuál podría
ser su configuración. Y como regla general,
queremos poner el átomo menos electronegativo, que
no sea el hidrógeno, al centro. Hemos hablado de
esto antes. Podemos ver en nuestra tabla periódica
que el flúor es el elemento más electronegativo,
así que intentemos poner al silicio al centro y
hagamos al flúor nuestro átomo terminal, es decir,
algo en el exterior. Así que intentémoslo, vamos a
poner al silicio en el centro; y, como necesitamos
poner los 4 átomos de flúor en algún sitio,
pongamos un flúor por aquí y otro flúor por acá,
otro flúor por acá y un flúor más por acá.
Ahora, en el siguiente paso vamos a decir,
por simplicidad, que tenemos sólo enlaces
sencillos entre el silicio y los átomos de flúor,
así que vamos a hacerlo: tenemos un enlace, otro
enlace, otro enlace y otro enlace. Ahora bien,
cada uno de estos enlaces covalentes, cada una
de estas líneas en nuestro diagrama de Lewis,
representa 2 electrones. Por ejemplo, esta línea
que dibujamos en color amarillo representa 2
electrones que son compartidos entre el flúor
y el silicio, esta otra línea representa otros
2 electrones que se comparten entre el silicio y
este otro flúor, esta otra línea representa otros
2 electrones que se comparten entre el silicio
y este flúor, y esta otra línea representa otros
y este otro flúor. Bien, hasta ahora, ¿cuántos
electrones hemos representado? Bueno, cada uno de
estos enlaces representa 2 electrones, entonces
tenemos 2, 4, 6, 8 electrones, y si restamos 8 de
32 nos quedan 24 electrones de valencia. Entonces,
la regla general será intentar que estos átomos
terminales tengan 8 electrones de valencia. En
general intentaremos realizar la regla del octeto
para cualquier átomo excepto el de hidrógeno,
ya que el hidrógeno sólo necesita obtener 2
electrones en su última capa. En este caso,
el flúor quiere obtener 8 electrones, ya tiene
2 que puede compartir, así que necesita 6 más,
vamos a agregarlos: 2, 4, 6; hagamos lo mismo
para este otro flúor: 2, 4, 6; lo mismo para
este otro flúor: 2, 4, 6; y, por último, pero
no menos importante, tenemos este otro flúor:
2, 4, 6. Ahora, ¿cuántos electrones más hemos
representado? Bueno, tenemos 6 de este flúor,
6 en el siguiente flúor, 6 más en el siguiente
y por último otros 6 más; entonces, 6 veces 4,
así que tenemos representados 24 electrones más.
Y con esto hemos usado a todos los electrones de
valencia. Esto es bastante bueno porque queríamos
representar todos los electrones de valencia,
queremos representarlos de alguna manera en
este diagrama de Lewis. Lo siguiente que debemos
revisar es si todos los átomos están completos con
respecto a la regla del octeto. Ya hemos visto que
los átomos de flúor están completos, cada uno de
ellos tiene 6 electrones que no están en un enlace
y además pueden compartir 2 electrones que están
en un enlace; entonces cada uno de ellos siente
que tiene 8 electrones externos, es decir, 8
electrones de valencia a su alrededor. Por su
parte, el silicio puede compartir en 4 enlaces,
cada uno de estos enlaces tiene 2 electrones,
por lo tanto, el silicio también satisface la
regla del octeto. Por lo tanto, podemos estar
seguros de que este es el diagrama de Lewis,
a veces llamado estructuras de Lewis para el
tetrafluoruro de silicio. Entonces, para dejar más
claro lo que acabamos de hacer, vamos a ver estos
pasos a seguir que espero que te resulten bastante
intuitivos, y es por esto que no te los enseñé
desde el principio. Como puedes ver, el paso uno
es: "Encuentra el número total de electrones de
valencia". Hicimos eso: teníamos 4 de silicio
y 28 de los átomos de flúor. Después dicen:
"Agrega un electrón por cada carga negativa.
Resta un electrón por cada carga positiva".
No tuvimos que hacerlo en este ejemplo, ya que
tenemos una molécula neutra. Después nos dicen:
"Elige el átomo central" que debe ser el átomo
menos el electronegativo, excepto el hidrógeno,
y por esto elegimos al silicio, ya que el flúor
es el átomo más electronegativo, "y dibuja los
enlaces". Vimos que los enlaces representaban 8
electrones. "Resta los electrones usados del total
que se obtuvo en el paso 1." Y esto sólo es para
tener un seguimiento de la cantidad de electrones
de valencia que vamos representando. Después nos
quedamos con 24 de ellos. El siguiente paso es:
"Asigna los electrones sobrantes a los átomos
terminales". Fue por esto que asignamos estos
pares libres de electrones a los átomos de
flúor, le dimos 6 electrones extra a cada
uno y con esto pudimos ajustarlos completamente
a la regla del octeto, y después restamos estos
electrones del total, sólo para asegurarnos
de que estamos usando todos los electrones.
Y es justo lo que nos dicen: "Resta los
electrones usados del total del paso 2". Y
vimos que representamos todos nuestros electrones.
Por último, el paso 4 dice: "De ser necesario,
asigna los electrones sobrantes al átomo central".
No tuvimos que hacer esto en este ejemplo. Si el
átomo central se ajusta al octeto o excede el
octeto, entonces has terminado. En este caso se
ajusta al octeto, entonces terminamos. Finalmente
dice: "Si el átomo central no tiene el octeto,
crea enlaces múltiples". Una vez más, este ejemplo
fue bastante simple, ya que solamente necesitamos
enlaces sencillos, pero en ejemplos futuros
vamos a ver dónde podremos utilizar algunos
de estos pasos más matizados. Por ahora lo
dejaré aquí, nos vemos en el siguiente video.